[Applause]
all right welcome it's great to see
everyone here really excited about this
opportunity as you know our AI
accelerator has officially kicked off
all of your teams are ready to go and we
wanted this to be an opportunity to sort
of as a team come together and develop
some common foundations some common
technological foundation some common
language for talking about these very
challenging AI problems and so with that
I'll hand it over to Vijay all right
we'll kick off with the first lecture
which basically provides some overview
AI context for this you know again
welcome to the class we're really
looking forward to this what we're gonna
present this morning is really a lot of
overview material right many of you here
are you know know a lot in AI and
machine learning this is really meant to
just sort a level set before we start
the program before we start these
classes so you can see this generic
title artificial intelligence and
machine learning and we're gonna try and
cover all of that in about an hour so
some details might be skipped but what
we'll try and hit some of the the
salient features all of these slides are
available for you to use so if you're
presenting back to your own teams please
feel free to pull from these slides you
know we've actually gone through over
over some time putting you know a good
set of survey and overview slides
together so if any of these are useful
to you
you know just email us or we'll make
them available to you you're more than
welcome to use any and all of these
slides if you're trying to kind of
present this back to other people so
with that let's begin so we're gonna do
a quick overview of artificial
intelligence again a lot of level
setting going on here we're gonna do a
quick deep dive these aren't the deepest
of dives again given the amount of time
that we have but just talk very quickly
about supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning and then
summarize and we can certainly stop for
questions philosophical debates
cetera towards the end we'll try not to
get a lot of the philosophical debates
on camera if we can all right so first
question what is artificial intelligence
and this is a question that probably a
lot of you get and I certainly have
received this from a number of people
and that actually takes a lot of it took
us a lot of time to come up with this
and so we are very fortunate to have
professor Winston spend some time with
us out at Lincoln Laboratory and we
actually brainstorm for you know could
however to really trying to come up with
what is a a good definition for what we
call artificial intelligence and what we
sort of came up with is that there are
two aspects to artificial intelligence
first that we should not that we should
not confuse with each other one is the
concept of narrow AI and another is a
concept of general AI and sometimes in
conversation we tend to conflate or mix
the two so narrow AI according to our
definition is the theory and development
of computer systems that perform tasks
that augment for human intelligence such
as perceiving classifying learning
abstracting reasoning and or acting
certainly in a lot of the programs that
we work in were very focused on narrow
AI and not necessarily the more general
AI which we define as full autonomy so
that's a very high-level definition of
what we mean by AI now many of you in
the crowd of probably saying well he has
been around for a while people have been
talking about this for 50 60 plus years
why now what is so special about it now
why why is this a conversation piece now
well from what we've seen it really is
the convergence of three different
communities that have come together the
first is the community on big data the
second is a community on computing and
in a lot of computing technologies and
finally a lot of research and results in
machine learning algorithms the other
one I forgot to put is dollar signs down
here people have basically figured out
how to make money off of selling
advertisements labeling cat pictures etc
so that's maybe the hidden why why now
in particular but these are the three
large technical areas that have evolved
over the past
decade or so to really make AI something
we discuss a lot today so when we talk
about AI there are a number of different
pieces which make up an AI system and
you know we love the algorithms people
but there's a lot more going on outside
of that so we've spent a significant
amount of effort just trying to figure
out what goes into an AI system and this
is what we call a canonical architecture
very much in line with Lincoln
Laboratory thinking we like to think of
an end-to-end pipeline what are the
various components and what are the
interconnections between these various
components so within our AI canonical
architecture shown here we go all the
way from sensors to the end user or
missions and a lot of the projects that
you all are working on are going to go
all the way from here to there a lot of
our class however for the next few weeks
is going to focus on sort of step one
where a lot of people get stuck so we
take data that comes in through either
structured or unstructured sources these
are typically passed into some sort of a
data conditioning or data curation step
this data is through that process
typically converted into some form of
information that that information is
then passed into a series of algorithms
maybe one or many algorithms there are
lots of them there is life beyond neural
networks once we pass them through the
algorithms these typically form this
information is converted into knowledge
is typically then passed into some sort
of a module that interacts with the end
user or a human or the mission and
that's what we call a human machine
teaming step and that finally that
knowledge with the human complement is
becomes insight that can be that can
then be used to execute the mission that
the AI system was created for all of
these components sit on the bedrock of
modern computing many different
technologies that make up modern
computing and the system that we're
using today has combination of some of
these computing Hardware elements and
certainly within the context of a lot of
the projects that we are interested in
all of this also needs to be wrapped in
a layer that we call robust AI which
consists of explainable artificial
intelligence
metrics and bias assessment verification
validation security and policy ethics
safety and training we'll talk very
briefly about each of these pieces in
detail in a little bit as I mentioned AI
has an extremely rich history this is
just a very Lincoln and MIT specific
view of the history of artificial
intelligence but certainly there's been
great work since the the folks of Minsky
Clark Dineen Oliver Selfridge etc since
the 50s we've seen a lot of work in the
80's and 90's and certainly recently
there's been again a resurgence of AI in
our parlance and our thinking of the way
AI works so without going into too much
detail about each of these eras and why
the winters came about etc what yeah I
think John launch period DARPA actually
put it very well when he talked about
different waves of AI technologies that
have come about and when he talks about
he talks about the three waves of AI or
the four waves of AI and the first wave
which you can kind of think of as the
first decade right of AI technology
resulted in a lot of reasoning based
systems which were which were based on
handcrafted knowledge so an example of
an output of this would be an expert
system right so a lot of work in that so
these if we kind of take the the four
dimensions that John launched burries
suggests of the ability of the system to
perceive learn abstract and reason these
are typically pretty good at reasoning
because they encoded human knowledge
right so a human expert sat down and
said sat down and said what's going on
in the system and try to write a series
of rules so tax software for example
does a pretty reasonable job of that
we're a chartered accountant or a tax
expert sits down encodes a series of
rules we have a question in the back
example of an expert system for my yep
so so the question is you know are there
examples of expert systems a certainly
one would be tax software my graduate
research was actually an autonomous
vehicle some of the early autonomous
vehicles used a form of expert systems
where the states on a finite state
machine were maybe handcrafted but the
end the transitions between them were
sort of designed that way there was some
machine learning wrapper around but
expert systems you know certainly played
a large part in some of the early of an
autonomous vehicle research that went on
alright so over time we we were able to
use these expert systems and you know
don't get me wrong these systems are
still extremely valid in cases where you
have limited data availability limited
compute power a lot of expert systems
still being used or in cases where
explain ability is a very important
factor you still see expert systems
because they do have the ability to
explain why they came up they can
typically point to a set of rules that
somebody wrote which is usually quite
interpretable by a human however as we
were able to collect more data we were
maybe able to understand a little bit
more about what was the underlying
process we were able to apply a
statistical learning and this sort of
led to the next era or next wave of AI
technologies which is often called the
learning wave and this was really
enabled by lots of data enabled non
expert system so what we mean by that is
we were able to kind of dial back the
amount of expert knowledge that we
encoded into the algorithm maybe put a
higher level of expert knowledge into
that but usually and then use data to
learn what some of these rules could be
an example of that in case someone wants
to ask would be in speech processing for
example so we were able to say well I
kind of realized that speech follows
this sort of you know
Gaussian mixture model so I can encode
that level of statistical knowledge but
I'm going to let the system sort of
figure out the details of how all that
actually works works out and there are
many other cases I again coming back to
some of the research I did on autonomous
vehicles we were able to maybe use some
high-level expert rules that there here
are a set of states that a car may be a
car may be in but I'm gonna let the
algorithm actually figure out when these
transitions occur and what constitutes a
transition between different states so
looking at the four feature the four
vectors that you could think about it
these systems had a little bit more on
perception obviously we're doing a lot
more learning but their ability to
abstract and reason was still was still
pretty low and by reasoning we mean you
know can you explain can you tell us
what's going on when you give me an
output to the result the next wave which
were maybe at the beginning stages of is
what we call contextual learning or
contextual adaptation this is where an
AI system can actually add context into
what it's doing I'm not sure I have too
many examples of people doing this very
well I think what most of most of the
work today probably falls into sort of
the the end stage of the learning wave
of AI but we're able to sort of combine
a bunch of these learning things to make
it look like it's contextual in nature
but the but the key concept over here is
being able to have the system
automatically abstract and reason so the
way that we we think about things right
so if I see a chair over here and I put
a chair somewhere else I still know it's
a chair because I'm using other contexts
maybe it's next to a table or stuff like
that
some early research going on in that
area and certainly the next wave of this
is what we call abstraction and there is
very little work on this but if we sort
of have to think out in the future but
this is really the system of an ability
the ability of an AI system to actually
abstract information that it's learning
so instead of learning that a chair is a
thing or a table is something with a leg
at the bottom it learns that a table is
something you put things on and is able
to abstract that information or that
knowledge
to any other any other domain or any
other field do we have any questions
before I continue from here okay great
so that's a little bit on the evolution
of AI the reason we like to go through
this is because you know there is great
work going on in each of these waves and
nothing nothing that people are doing in
any of these waves is any lesser or more
it's typically a dependent on what you
have at your disposal what I like to
tell people sometimes is the way to
think about all of this is you have a
couple of dials at your disposal right
turning dials the first dial is how much
compute right yes how much ability do
you have to crunch data the second piece
is how much data do you actually have
available and this can be labeled data
in many cases and the third dial is how
much knowledge are you able to embed
into an algorithm in certain cases where
maybe you have very little computing
very little data label data availability
but a lot of expert knowledge or a lot
of ability to encode information into an
algorithm you might be able to use an
expert system right and that's a that's
a very good use case for that an example
may be on another dimension where you
have you want to encode very little
human knowledge but you have a lot of
computing and data available would be
where neural networks fall in right
where they're essentially learning what
the human knowledge
you know what that encoded information
should be a lot of statistical
techniques also fall into that camp
where maybe you encode a little bit of
information as to like what the
background distribution of the process
is but it learns the details of exactly
how that distribution is modeled based
on the data that it sees so you have a
lot of different settings that you can
use and there are a number of different
techniques within the within the broader
AI context that you can use to achieve
your your mission I'm sure many of you
are going to be doing different types of
algorithms and a lot of that decision
will be dependent on well how much data
was I given right how how good is this
data that I'm using is
our inability to to learn anything from
this and if not you might have to encode
some knowledge of your own into it
saying well I kind of know that this
process looks like that so let me tell
the algorithm to not waste too much time
crunching the data to learn the
underlying distribution which I can tell
you why don't you learn the parameters
of the distribution instead that makes
sense right and as you know there's just
a lot going on in AI and machine
learning
you can't walk two steps without running
into somebody who's you know either
starting something up working for one of
these organizations so it's it's really
it really is an exciting time to be in
the field alright so that's a little bit
on the overview but let's talk now in a
little bit of detail on what some of the
critical components are within this AI
ki architecture so one thing that we
like to note and there's a reason that
as we've been reaching out to a number
of you we've been talking about getting
data right work with stakeholders to get
your data in place and the reason we
talk about that is data is critical to
breakthroughs in AI a lot of the press
maybe on the algorithms and the
algorithms that have been designed but
really when we've looked back in history
we've seen that while the availability
of a good canonical data set actually is
is is equally if not more critical to
breakthrough in AI so what we've done
here is we've just picked a select
number of breakthroughs in AI our
definition of a breakthrough in this
particular example is something that
made a lot of press or something that we
thought was really cool so here are some
examples of that in different years and
we've talked about the datasets sort of
the canonical data set that maybe led to
that breakthrough or that was cited in
that breakthrough as well as the
algorithms that were used in that
breakthrough and when they were first
proposed this is notional in nature you
clearly this you could adjust these
dates a few years here or there but what
we really want to get across is that the
average numbers a number of years to a
breakthrough from the availability of a
cool data set right are very important
well-structured well labeled data set
is much smaller than from the algorithms
first proposal when the algorithm first
comes out so as you're developing your
challenge problems as you're developing
your interactions with stakeholders
certainly something to keep in mind that
there's clearly a lot of algorithm
algorithmic research that's going to go
on but having a good strong well labeled
and documented data set can be equally
important and making that available to
the wider AI community the wider AI
ecosystem can be very very valuable to
your work and the work of many other
people all right so back to the AI
architecture we're going to just go
through very briefly different pieces of
this architecture so the first piece
we're going to talk about is the data
conditioning which is converting
unstructured and structured data within
the structured and unstructured data you
might have structured sources coming
from sensors you know network logs for
some of you metadata associated with
sensors may be speech or other such
signals there's also a lot of
unstructured data you think of things
that you might collect from the internet
that you might download from say a
social media site maybe it reports other
types of sensors that maybe don't have
well that don't have strong structure
within the data set itself and typically
this first step consists of an um you
know what we call the data conditioning
step consists of a number of different
elements you might want to first figure
out where to put this data that can
often take a lot of time and there have
been religious wars fought on this on
this topic we're here to tell you that
you're probably okay picking most
technologies but if you have any
questions you know feel free to reach
out to me or to others on the team we
have a lot of opinions on you know
what's the right infrastructure to solve
the problem typically these
infrastructure databases might provide
capabilities such as indexing
organization and structure very
important in unstructured data right to
convert it into some format that you can
do things with they may allow you to
connect to them using domain-specific
languages so it's sort of converting
into a language that maybe you're used
to talking they can perform provide high
performance data access and in many
cases a declarative interface because
maybe you don't really care about how
the data is being accessed you want to
just say select the data give it to me
and then move forward from there another
important part of the data conditioning
step is data curation this unfortunately
will probably take you a very long time
and this is it requires a lot of
knowledge of the data itself what you
want to do with the data and how you
receive the data but what you might do
in the data curation step is you know
perform some sort of unsupervised
learning maybe reduce the dimensionality
of your problem you might do some
clustering or pattern recognition to
maybe remove certain pieces of your data
or to highlight certain pieces of the
data that look important you might do
some outlier detection you might
highlight missing values you might
there's this dot dot dot etc etc etc a
lot goes on in the data curation step we
could certainly spend hours just talking
about that and the final thing
especially within the context of subha
supervised machine learning but even in
the world of unsupervised learning would
be spending some time on data labeling
right so this is taking data that you've
received typically doing an initial data
exploration it could be as simple as
opening it up in Excel to see what the
different columns and rows look like if
it if that's a suitable way place to
open it up you might look for highlight
missing or incomplete data just from
your initial data exploration you might
be able to go back to the data provider
or to the sensor and say you know can
you reorient the sensors or recapture
the data you know I noticed that every
time you've measured this particular
quantity it always shows up as three I
can't imagine that that's correct
can you go back and tell me if that
sensor is actually working or is it
actually three in which case you might
want to know that and you might look for
errors biases and collection you know of
course on top of the actual labeling
process that you're doing to highlight
phenomenology within the data that you'd
like to then
look for through your machine learning
algorithms oh I'll pause for a second
yes so the question is what's the ratio
we see between structured and
unstructured data that's a great
question so the ratio in terms of the
volume of the ratio in terms of what you
can do with it because those are
actually almost the the opposite so
again I'm talking about a few data sets
that I'm very familiar with the
unstructured data can often be 90% of
the volume and 10 person you know maybe
the 10% is the metadata associated with
the unstructured data most of the value
however comes from the structured data
where people really analyze the crap out
of the structured data because they know
how to there is certainly a lot of you
know a lot of potential within the
unstructured data so that when we when
we talk to people we that's why we talk
a lot about infrastructure and data
bases as being an important first step
because if you can just take the
unstructured data and put it into a
structured or semi structured form that
itself can provide a lot of value
because there's very often in problems
that we see you know sort of the 90%
volume of data is largely untapped
because people don't know how to get
into it or don't know what to do with it
or it's not in a form that you can
really deal with so when I think next
class we're going to be talking to you
about how to organize your data right
strategies for organizing data that can
get you a lot more value out of the
unstructured data does that answer your
question
yes
is it typically like you
you
so the question is when you apply AI or
machine learning techniques to a problem
domain is it typically a single modality
or multiple modalities I'd say the
answer is both certainly there's a lot
of research and you know back there we
have Matthew who's actually doing
research on that right now
on how to fuse multiple modalities of
data I know a lot of projects that are
that are being discussed here are
certainly looking at multiple modalities
if I had to say as of today a lot of the
work that's out there right the sort of
published work may be focused on a
single modality but that's not to say I
mean I think there is a lot of value on
multiple modalities but the challenge
still comes up on how do you integrate
this data especially if they're
collected from different systems because
the technologies that can purse the
waveform and all of this data
conditioning or mature enough so the
question is why would speech or
something else like that fall into
structured versus unstructured and
you're absolutely right I think when we
pick speech and I'm sure there are
others in the room that might disagree
with that and might stick it over here
when we look at the type of acquisition
processes that are used as a software
that's used they typically come out with
some known metadata they follow a
certain pattern that we can then use
right there is a clear range to where
the there's a the frequency to which the
data is collected and that's why we
stuck it in the structured data type of
course if you're collecting data out in
the field without without that you could
probably stick it into the unstructured
world as well but that's probably a good
example of something that can fall in
between the two places
okay right now for the part everyone's
really interested in machine learning
right so alright you got through the
boring data conditioning stuff which
will take you yeah a couple of years or
something like that you know nothing
nothing serious and now you're ready to
do the machine learning and now you're
you're you're given a choice well which
algorithm do you use neural networks you
might say right I I there's a lot more
though beyond the neural network world
so there's numerous taxonomy --zz I'm
going to give you two of them today for
how you describe machine learning
algorithms one that's really kind of an
interesting way is from Pedro Dominguez
at the University of Washington in which
he sort of says that there are five
tribes of machine learning
so there are the symbolist switch an
example of that would be expert systems
there are the Bayesian tribes which an
example of an algorithm within that may
be naive Bayes there are the analogized
analogize errs which an example of that
would be a support vector machine and
the connectionists an example of which
would be deep neural networks and
evolutionary's an example of that which
might be genetic programming what what
really you know I'm trying to get across
I'm sure the author is trying to get
across here is that lots and lots of
different algorithms each have their
relative merits and relative strengths
apply the right one for your application
apply the right one for again given
these dials that I talked about earlier
the amount of computing that you have
available the amount of data that you
have available and the amount of expert
knowledge that you're able to encode
into your algorithm that you think is
generalizable enough if we actually talk
about this is a very useful chart I've
found in describing to folks that are
not familiar with AI that might say well
isn't a I just neural networks and
neural networks are a part of AI but not
necessarily all of it so if we kind of
think of the the big circle is the broad
field of artificial intelligence within
that is the world of machine learning
within machine learning our you know
connectionists or neural networks to
sort of fall into a small camp within
that
deep neural networks is sort of a part
of neural network so can anyone maybe
give me an example although I've said it
numerous times or something that might
fall out of machine learning but into
artificial intelligence from an
algorithmic point of view yes
graph search could be an example I would
maybe stick that into some of the
connectionists however yes exactly so
expert systems is sort of the one that
comes to my mind or knowledge based
systems are an example of maybe
something that falls outside of the
realm of machine learning again in the
very strict sense but maybe within the
realm of artificial intelligence from an
algorithmic point of view okay so that's
a little bit on the algorithms next
let's talk about some of the modern
computing engines that are out there I
mentioned that data compute as well as
algorithms have been key drivers to the
resurgence of AI over the past few years
what are some of these computing
technologies for example so clearly CPUs
and GPUs they're they're very popular
computing platforms lots of software
written to work with these computing
platforms
but what we're seeing now is that with
the end of Moore's Law and a lot more
performance engineering going on we're
seeing a lot more work research and
hardware architectures that are custom
in nature and custom architectures are
almost like the new commercial off to
sell off-the-shelf solutions that are
out there so an example of a custom
architecture could be Google's tensor
processing unit or TPU
there's some very exciting research
going on in the world of neuromorphic
computing I'm happy to chat with you all
later if you're interested to know
what's going on in that area and maybe
our role in some of that work and
there's just some stuff that you know we
would still call custom these are still
people deciding you know designing
basically looking at an algorithm saying
ok here's the data layout here is the
movement of day
or information within this within this
algorithm let's create a custom
processor does that does that an example
of that could be the graph processor
which is being developed at Lincoln
Laboratory and you know obviously know
no slide on computing architectures or
computing technologies would be complete
without mentioning the word quantum in
it
there's some early results on you know
solving linear system of equations but I
think applied to AI it's still unsure or
unknown or unproven where quantum eight
play a part but certainly a technology
that all of us I'm sure I've heard of
are continue to track and are just
interested in seeing where that where
that goes to so within the within the
first few however these are all products
that you can buy today you can go out to
your favorite your your computing store
and just purchase these off-the-shelf
solutions a lot of software has been
written to work with these different
technologies and it's it's a really nice
time to be involved
okay so the exam the question is what
you know can I think about neuromorphic
what should I think about when I'm
thinking about neuromorphic so there's a
few features which I say fall into the
camp of what people are calling
neuromorphic computing one is what
they're calling a brain inspired
architecture which often means it's
clock las' so you typically have some
sort of a so a lot of these technologies
have clocked right movement of
information these might be clock less in
nature they typically sit on top of
different types of memory architectures
and the you know trying to think of what
would be another parameter that would be
that would be very useful let me send
you I can probably send you a couple
things that that help I'll I highlight
that have certainly wouldn't call myself
an expert in this area but yeah I think
the the term that's used is it's
supposed to mimic the brain in the way
that the computing architecture actually
performs our functions so lots of
research as well and this is work that
we've done here at the lab on actually
trying to map the performance of these
different processors and how they
perform for different types of functions
so what what we're doing here is
basically looking at the power on the x
axis and the y axis is the peak
performance and Giga operations per
second different types of precision are
noted over there by the different shapes
of the boxes and then different form
factors and the idea here is basically
to say there's so much going on in the
world of computing how can we compare
them they all have their own individual
areas where they're strong so one can't
come up and say well the GPU is better
than the CPU well it depends on what
you're trying to do and what your goals
of the operation are so some of the the
key lines to kind of note here is that
there seems to be a lot of existing
systems on this hundred Giga operations
per watt on this line over here this
dashed line some of the newer offerings
may be fit into the one tera op per watt
and some of the research chips like
IBM's TrueNorth or area or intel's area
fall into the sort of just a bit under
the tent our operations per what sort of
line that we see there but you know
depending on the type of application you
may be okay with a certain amount of
peak power so if you're looking at
embedded applications you're probably
somewhere over here right if you're
trying to get something that's you know
on on a little drone or something like
that you might want to go here and if
you have a data center you're probably
okay with that type of power utilization
or peak power utilization but you do
need the performance that goes along
with that so I'd say the most important
parts to look at are essentially these
different lines those are the different
those are the sort of the trajectories
for maybe some of the existing systems
all the way up to some of the more
research-oriented processors out there
okay alright so we we talked about
modern computing let's talk a little bit
about the robust AI side of things and
the basic idea between robust AI
is that it's extremely important and the
reason that it's important is that the
consequence of actions on certain
applications of AI can be quite high so
what we've done here is kind of think
about you know where are the places that
maybe humans and machines have their
relative strengths so on the x-axis
we're talking about the consequence of
action so this could be to somebody get
hurt if the system doesn't do the right
thing all the way down to no worries if
the system doesn't do the right thing
right which could be you know maybe some
of the labeling of images that we see
online might fall into this category I'm
sure people disagree with me on that but
maybe a lot of national security
applications a Health application
certainly fall into the area of you know
high consequence of action if you give
someone the wrong treatment that's kind
of a deal and then on the y-axis we're
talking about the confidence level in
the Machine making the decision so how
much confidence do we have in the system
that's actually making the decision in
certain cases we might have very high
confidence in the system that's making a
decision and obviously in certain cases
we do not have much confidence in the
system making the
so in areas where you have a low
consequence of action maybe high
confidence level in the machine making
the decision we might say those are best
match to machines those are good
candidates for automation on the on the
contrary there might be areas where the
consequence of action is very high and
we have very little confidence in the
system that's making the decision
probably an area we want humans to be
intricately if not solely or involved or
responsible and the area in between is
where machines might be augmenting
humans is anybody want to venture a
couple of you know maybe a couple of
examples help come up with a couple of
examples here that you might put into
each of these categories so maybe what's
what's a good problem that you can think
of that might be best matched to
machines beyond labeling images for
advertisements assembly lines
yep that's a good example thinking
within like spam filtering could be
another example where there is I mean it
there is some machine augmenting human
it does send you an email saying this is
spam are you sure but for the most part
it's largely automated I'd say a lot of
the work that many of us are probably
doing falls into this category maybe on
different sides of the spectrum but of
where machines are augmenting humans so
the system can be providing you know
data back to a human that can then
select it might filter information out
for humans that then the humans can then
go ahead and say okay well instead of
looking at a thousand documents I could
only look at ten which is much better
and then there's obviously certain
probably we want humans to be heavily
involved with any kinetic you know
anything that involves life or death we
probably want and they're probably legal
reasons also that we want humans
involved with things like that one of
the examples that you know we often get
which is you know autonomous vehicles
and it's always a little confusing where
autonomous vehicles fall into this
certainly the consequence of action of a
mistake an autonomous vehicle can be
pretty high and as of today the
confidence in the decision-making is
medium at best but people still seem to
somehow be okay with fully automating
that just shows how terrible Boston
roads or driving in general is that
we're like I'm not really sure if this
thing will kill me or not but totally
worth the worth worth trying it out sort
of slowly expand the yellow yes I'd say
that the question is you know is the is
the yellow expanding I think so I you
know what one could make the argument
that is it shifting that direction are
we finding areas where and I think
that's maybe the direction I'm where we
are probably looking at automating
certain things a little bit more as
confidence and decision-making goes up
so you might think about this frontier
sort of moving down so that maybe the
green expanding slightly and the yellow
kind of taking over a little bit of the
red there might be some places where
over time we're more open to the Machine
making a decision and the human having
largely supervisory supervise having a
largely supervisory role which I would
put right at this frontier between the
yellow and the red
I can think of some examples but maybe
I'll share it with them share it with
you later so certainly robust artificial
intelligence plays a very important part
in the development and deployment of AI
systems I won't go through the details
of each of these I'm sure many of you
are very familiar with it and I know a
few of you are far more knowledgeable
about this maybe than I am but some of
the key features would be explainable AI
which is a system being able to describe
what it's doing in an interpretable
fashion metrics so being able to provide
the right metric right if you want to go
beyond accuracy or performance
validation and verification there might
be cases where you're not really
concerned about the explained ability
but you just want to know that when I
pass an input I get an own output out of
it and is there a way to confirm that
I'm able to do that another could be on
security so an example of this are not
having security to be counter AI right
so when we talk about security within
the context of robust AI it's almost
like the cryptographic way of thinking
about it which is can I protect the
confidentiality integrity and
availability of my algorithm the data
sets the outputs the the weights the
biases etc and finally of a lot of
significant importance is policy ethics
safety and training this is actually
very important in some of those
applications where you know in the
previous slide we had the yellow and the
red where humans and machines augmenting
humans where that falls a lot of that
might be governed by policy ethic safety
and training which is some of the
examples that I can think of where there
are policy reasons that make it that
only a human can be involved with this
may be with minimal input from a system
okay and the final sort of component of
our AI architecture we've gone through
conditioning algorithms computing robust
AI is human machine teaming and think
what we want to get across with human
machine teaming that is it really
depends on the application and what
you're trying to do but it is important
to think about the human in the machine
working together and there's this
there's a spectrum of where the machine
will largely will play a large part in a
human largely supervisory or to where
the human plays a large part and the
machine is you know very targeted in
what you do with the machine or the AI
of the system but a couple of ways to
think about it would be of course you
know we talked about the confidence
level versus consequence of actions but
also the scale versus application
complexity so on the top chart over
there we have on the the x-axis is the
application complexity how complex is
this application and on the y-axis is
sort of the scale you know how many
times do you need to keep doing this
thing places that machines might be more
effective than humans or where we have
low application complexity but very very
high scale so again spam filtering falls
into this the complexity of spam
filtering has gone up over time but is
something that you know is is is
reasonable within systems but the scale
is very high that we just don't want a
human being involved with that process
and on the other end of the spectrum is
where you have very high application
complexity that'll only happen a couple
of times so this could be say reviewing
a situation you know maybe a company's
trying to make an acquisition it's not
going to happen over and over so you
might have a human involved with with
that that kind of goes through a lot of
that may be they target the system to go
look for specific pieces of information
but really it's the human that might be
more effective in that especially given
that the situation would change over and
over all right so with that we're going
to take a quick tour of the world of
machine learning I'll stop there for a
second any questions
okay all right so what is machine
learning always a good place to start
it's the study of algorithms to improve
their performance and some tasks at some
task with experience and in this context
experiences data and they typically do
this by optimizing based on some
performance criteria that uses example
data or past experience so in the world
of supervised learning that could be the
example data or past experience could be
the correct label given an input data
set input data point machine learning is
a combination of tikrit techniques from
statistics computer in computer science
communities and it's the idea of getting
computers to sort of program themselves
common tasks within the world of machine
learning could be things like
classification regression prediction
clustering etc for those who are maybe
kind of making the shift to machine
learning from traditional programming I
found this again for Pedro Domingos to
be a very useful way of sort of
describing it to people so in
traditional programming you have a data
set you write a program which would be
if you see this do that when you see
this do that you know for this many
instances do the following thing on it
and then write an output out right so
you input a data into the program into a
computer and the computer produces an
output where it says okay I've applied
this program on that data and this gives
me the output machine learning is sort
of a very different way of thinking
about it in which you're almost
inputting the data as well as the output
so in this case the data could be
unlabeled images the output could be the
labels associated with those images and
you tell the computer figure out what
the program would look like and that's
just a slightly different way of
thinking about machine learning versus
traditional programming what are some of
these programs or algorithms that the
computer might use to figure it out so
within the within the the large realm of
machine learning we have supervised
unsupervised reinforcement learning what
we have in the brackets is essentially
what you're providing in the world in
the case of supervised learning you're
providing labels which is the correct
label associated with an input feature
or with an input data
set a data point in unsupervised
learning you typically have no labels
but also are limited by what the
algorithm itself can do and in the world
of reinforcement learning you're
providing instead of a label per data
point you're providing the reward
information to the system that says if
you're doing more if you're doing the
right thing I'm going to give you some
points if you're doing the wrong thing
I'm gonna take away some points very
useful in like very complex applications
where you you can't really figure out
the the labels associated with each data
point within the world of supervised
learning the typical tasks that people
have and I should note before I go
through this there's a lot of overlap
between all of these different pieces so
this is a high-level view and but we can
certainly argue about the specific
positioning of everything I'm sure we
can
so within supervised learning you can
fall into classification regression
unsupervised learning is typically
clustering dimensionality reduction and
within these there are different
algorithms that that fall into place so
examples could be things like neural
nets which sort of cover all of these
spaces get logistic regression PCA which
might fall into dimensionality reduction
lots and lots of different techniques
and also some in the reinforcement
learning world and there's just more and
more and more if you open up a survey of
machine learning it's it'll give you
even more than all of these techniques
over here and the thing to remember when
you're using machine learning is that
there are some common pitfalls that you
can fall into an example of that would
be overfitting versus under fitting
where you you come up with this awesome
model that does really really well on
your training data you apply it to your
test data and you get terrible results
you might not have your you might have
done a really good job learning the
training data but not necessarily
learning being able to generalize beyond
that sometimes it could be just the
algorithm itself is unable to correctly
model the behavior that's exhibited by
the training and test data I won't go
through each of these again but there
might just be bad noisy missing data
that certainly happens
you end up with an algorithm with
terrible results and you look at it and
you're like why is that and you actually
look at the data that you did and it was
incorrect that there was just missing
features or it was noisy in nature such
that the actual phenomenology that you
are trying to look for was hidden within
the noise you might have picked the
wrong model you might have used a linear
model in a nonlinear case where the
phenomenology are trying to describe is
nonlinear in nature but maybe you use a
linear model you've not done a good job
of separating training versus testing
data etc etc so we'll just take a quick
view into each of these different
learning paradigms so the first is on
supervised learning and you basically
start with labelled data or what we call
grows often refer to as ground truth and
you build a model that predicts labels
given new pieces of data and you have
two general goals one is to one is in
regression which is to predict some sort
of a continuous variable or a
classification which is to predict a
class or label so if we kind of look at
this the the diagram on the right we
have training data that we provide which
is data and labels that goes into a
train model the that's typically an
iterative process where we find out well
did we do a good job that that is now
called the supervised learning model
that we then apply new data or test data
or unseen data to and look at the
predicted labels typically when you are
designing an algorithm like this you'd
separate out you take your training data
you'd remove a small portion of it that
you do know the labels for that's your
test data over here and and then you
kind of run that and you can see well is
it working well or not and most of these
algorithms have a training step that
forms a model so when we talk about
machine learning and in the super both
the supervised and unsupervised sense
we'll often talk about training the
model which is this process and then
inference which is the second step which
is where you apply unseen data so this
is the the trained model in deployment
or in the field it's performing
inference at that point
of course no class these days on machine
learning and AI could go without talking
about neural networks and as I mentioned
neural networks do form a very important
a part of machine learning and they
certainly are an algorithm that many of
you I'm sure are familiar with and they
they fall well within the supervised and
unsupervised and they've been used for
so many different applications at this
point so what's a neural network a
computing system inspired by biological
networks and the system essentially
learns by repetitive training to do
tasks based on examples much of the work
that we've seen is typically it being
applied to supervised learning though
I'll mention some that we are doing some
research and actually applying it for
unsupervised learning as well and
they're in there quite powerful the
components of a neural network include
inputs layers outputs and weights so
these are often the terms that someone
will use and a deep neural network has
lots of hidden layers does anyone here
have a better definition for what deep
in neural network means beyond lots for
definitions anywhere three and above yes
more than one layer but not necessarily
one
okay so so one definition here for deep
is and this is anyone have a better no
that's the the the one to beat right now
is is sort of a feature of a deep neural
network could be recurrence within the
network architecture which implies that
there you know that there is some sort
of depth to the overall network so above
three with recurrence deep alright
lots of variants within the supervised
world of of of neural networks such as
convolutional neural network for cursive
neural networks deep belief networks one
of I think in my opinion again since
you've all asked me to opine here no
you've not but I think a reason that
these are so popular these days is
there's so many tools out there that are
very easy to use you can just go online
and within about five minutes write your
first neural network try writing a
hidden Markov model that quickly maybe
there are people who can but in general
in general so what are the features of a
deep neural network so you have some
sort of input features you have weights
which are essentially associated with
each line over here as well as biases
for each of the layers that sort of
govern the interaction between the
layers and then an output layer so these
input features can often be combined to
each other so these feature vectors that
are coming in can often be combined I
think Jeremy will talk a little bit
about how they the matrix view of all of
this but you can kind of think of it as
if you're an example could be if you
have an image it could be the pixel the
RGB pixel values of each of each pixel
in that image could be the input feature
so you could have large numbers of input
features if you have a time series
signal it could be the amplitude or the
magnitude at a particular frequency or
at a particular step there's often a
combination of features that you might
do so in addition to the pixel
intensities for an image you might also
then combine the spatial distance
between two pixels or its position
within the image may also be another
input feature
and you can really go hog-wild over here
just trying to come up with new features
and there's a lot of research just in
that area which is I take a dataset that
everyone knows and I'm just gonna spend
a lot of time doing feature engineering
which is coming up with what is the
right way to to do the features so
coming back to an earlier question this
is an area where people are often
looking at supplementing maybe a given
data set with additional data and then
fusing those two pieces together for
example could be audio and text together
as input features to a network that you
can then learn that might do a better
job but all of this you know sort of
governed by this really really simple
but powerful equation which is that the
output at the I plus one layer is given
by some nonlinear function of the
weights multiplied by the inputs from
the previous step plus some sort of a
bias term then and when you're learning
when you're training a machine learning
model you're essentially trying to
figure out what the W's are and what the
B's are that's really what a model is
defined as so if we kind of zoom into
one of these pieces it's it's actually
pretty straightforward what's going on
over here so you have your inputs that
are coming from the previous layer so
this could be your Y sub I here are the
different weight so w1 w2 w3 these are
the connections are the weights going
into a neuron or a node and you know
performing some function on these inputs
and that function is referred to as an
activation function so let's just take
an example where we have some actual
numbers maybe I've gone through I've
trained my models I figured out that in
this just for this one dot in that big
network that we saw earlier that my
weights are two point seven eight point
six and zero point zero zero two my
inputs from the previous layer would be
is maybe negative zero point zero six
two point five one point four and all
I'm doing is coming up with this X which
is negative zero point zero six x two
point seven plus two
point five times eight point six plus
one point four times that that gives me
some number twenty one point thirty-four
I apply my nonlinear function which in
this case is a sigmoid governed by that
equation at the top right and I say F of
twenty one point three four so somewhere
way over there is approximately one
right so this probably a little less
than one but approximately one for the
for the purpose of this and you just do
that over and over so really a neural
network that I think the power of a
neural network is it allows you to
encode a lot less information than many
of the other machine learning algorithms
out there at the cost typically have a
lot more data being used and a lot more
computing being used but for many people
that's perfectly fine right and but it
does take it's just over and over back
and forth back and forth back and forth
to come up with what's the right double
use in order for this to give me a
result that looks reasonable lots of you
know lots of work going on in just
deciding the right activation function I
showed you a sigmoid over there we do a
lot of work with riilu units you know
the choice is you know there are certain
applications certain I should say
domains or applications or people have
found that a particular activation
function tends to work well but that's
that choice is something I kind of leave
to domain experts to maybe look at their
problem and figure out what are the
relative advantages each of these kind
of have their own advantages I know like
for example one of the big advantages of
rectified linear unit is that since
you're not limiting yourself between a
negative one zero and one range you
don't have to do that you don't run into
a problem of vanishing gradients that
doesn't mean much for people that's okay
we're not I spend too much time talking
about that anyhow yep
hmm
that's a so the question is picking the
activation functions picking the number
of layers we'll talk about that in a
couple of slides but there is a lot of
art trial-and-error yes but also a you
know call it art as well that's involved
with with coming up with that a lot of
what happens in practice however is you
find an application area which looks
very similar to the problem that you're
trying to solve and you might borrow the
architecture from there and kind of use
that as a starting point in coming up
with coming up with where you start I'm
not I'm sure people are doing it I'm
personally not familiar with that
research I don't know if anyone else in
the room has yep okay
you're trying to learn close the
architecture Network the activation
function or all the other attributes
because you try to just go from DSM to
machine learning system with no
intervention so the question was is
there any research into parametrizing
the activation functions I guess the
model as a whole
so yeah there there's there is and and
you know one of the responses was that
there is a program run by DARPA which is
the d3m program which is really looking
at you know can you go from data to
result with no or almost no human
intervention so that would be there
certainly I'm not familiar with
activation function parameterization but
certainly network model parametrizations
absolutely there so people who are
running optimization models to basically
look for I have this particular set of
resources what is the best model
architecture that fits into that you
know maybe I want to deploy this on a
really tiny processor that only gives me
you know 16 megabytes of memory I want
to make sure that my model and data can
fit on that can you find what would be
the ideal ideal model for that so that's
absolutely something that people are
doing right now but I'm not sure if
people are like trying to come up with I
guess brand new activation functions
all right so lots lots of stuff in the
neural network landscape and as I
mentioned earlier neural network
training is essentially adjusting waits
until the function represented by the
neural network essentially does what you
would like it to do and the key idea
here is to iteratively adjust weights to
reduce the error so what you do is you
take some random instantiation of your
neural network or maybe based on another
domain or another problem you might
borrow that and you kind of start there
and then you pass the data set in you
look at the output and you say hmm
that's not right what went wrong over
here and you kind of adjust kind of go
back and adjust things and do that again
and again and again and again and again
over and over until you get something
that looks reasonable that's really
what's going on over there and so real
neural networks can have thousands of
input data points hundreds of layers and
millions to billions of weight changes
per iteration yes
[Music]
yes there's a lot of work being done to
paralyze this and and by default so the
question is is you know when as I just
described it right now it's a serial
process where I pass one data point in
it detector goes all the way to the end
it you know it says this is the output
goes back and adjusts are there
techniques that people are doing to do
this in a distributed fashion and the
answer to that is is a strong yes it's a
very active area in especially high
performance computing and machine
learning we might talk about this in are
we talking about this on day three we
might we might talk a little bit about
it but there is you know model
parallelism which is I have the model
itself distributed across multiple
pieces and I want to it adjust different
pieces of the model at the same time
there's research and lots of results I
think we might even have some examples
that people are doing with that
a little bit earlier yeah so there are
many different ways to paralyze it one
would be data parallelism which is I
take my big data set or big data point
and I distribute that across my
different nodes and each one kind of
independently learns a model that works
well and then I do some sort of
synchronization across these different
pieces there are also techniques where
you have the model itself may be too big
to sit on a single node or a single
processing element you might have to
distribute that so yes a lot of a lot of
very interesting research going on in
that area and by default you're when you
do run things they are running in
parallel just even on your GPU they're
using multiple cores at once so there is
some level of sort of within the node
itself parallelism that runs by default
on most most machine learning software
so inference as I mentioned is just
using the Train model again and the
power of neural networks really falls
within their non-linearity so you have
that nonlinear F function that you're
applying over and over and over across
your layers and this crudely drawn
diagram on my iPad is not clear at all
it's the you know if you had X's and O's
it reminds me of a song and you have
features over here and you're trying to
basically classify you know which is an
X and which is an O a linear classifier
I could go do a pretty good job in this
type of situation and you know you could
apply a neural network to this but maybe
it's overkill in that type of situation
but in in some sort of a feature space
if this is how your X's and O's are
divided divided amongst each other and
you're trying to come up with the right
label you know one thing I might suggest
is maybe find another feature space that
you could maybe get a better separation
between the two or a technique like a
neural network might do a very good job
or any of these nonlinear machine
learning techniques might do a very good
job for looking for these really complex
decision boundaries that are out there
all right so you mentioned earlier you
know when you're designing a neural
network what are what do you have to do
like what are the different choices etc
there's a lot going on here so you get
you have to pick
the depth the number of layers the
inputs and what the inputs are the type
of network that you're using the types
of layers the training algorithm and
metrics that you're using to assess the
performance of this neural network the
good thing however is it is so expensive
to train a neural network that you
largely are not making these decisions
in many cases you just pick up what
somebody else has done and you start
from there and then you start that's
your that might be I don't know if
that's a good or a bad thing
but that that's often a way in practice
that people end up doing this but there
is some there is some theory on like the
general approach I think in the in this
short amount of time which I'm already
over we we won't be able to get into it
but I'm happy to actually these slides
have backups on them so when I share
them with you that do have a lot more
detail on each of these different pieces
all right very quickly we'll talk about
unsupervised learning and the basic idea
is the task of describing a hidden
structure from unlabeled data so in
contrast to supervised learning we are
not providing labels we're just giving
the algorithm a data set and saying tell
me something cool that's going on over
here now clearly you can only do you you
can't you can't label the data if you do
that but what you can do is maybe look
for clusters or look for dimensions or
pieces of the data that are that are
unimportant or extraneous so if we
observe certain features we would like
to observe the patterns amongst these
features and the typical tasks that one
would do in unsupervised learning is
clustering and data projection or data
pre-processing or dimensionality
reduction and the goal is to discover
interesting things about the data set
such as subgroups patterns clusters etc
in unsupervised learning one of the one
of the difficulties in supervised
learning we know right we have an input
we have a label and we're like okay if
that input if my algorithm doesn't give
me the label bad go you know retrain or
I know what you know I can kind of go
back use that as my performance metric
on unsupervised learning there is no
simple goal such as maximizing a certain
probability for the algorithm some of
that is going to be you know something
that you have to work on is it the inter
class or intra class distance that I'm
most you know kind of having that
separation is that going to be my
performance metric is it the number of
clusters that I'm creating is that the
is that the metric that I'm using but it
is very popular because it works on
unlabeled data and I'm sure many of us
work on datasets which are just too
large or too difficult to sit and label
an example that that comes to my mind
certainties in the world of
cybersecurity where you're collecting
billions and billions of network packets
and you're trying to look for anomalous
behavior you're not going to go through
and look at each pack and be like bad
good you know what it is but you might
use an unsupervised technique to maybe
extract out some of the relevant pieces
then use the supervised you know then go
through the trouble of labeling that
data and then pass that on to a
supervised learning technique and I'm
happy to share some research that we've
been doing on that front some common
techniques are within clustering and
data projection clustering is the basic
idea that we want to group objects or
sets of features such that objects in
the same cluster are more similar to
those of another cluster and what you
typically do for that is you put your
data in some feature space and you try
to maximize some sort of an intra
cluster measure which is basically
saying I want the points within my
cluster to be closer than anything
outside of my cluster right so that's
that's a metric and you sort of
iteratively move the membership from
each but you you you set a number of
clusters saying I need five clusters
it'll randomly assign things and it'll
keep adjusting the membership of a
particular data point within a cluster
based on a metrics such as the squared
error so in this example we might say
that okay these are three clusters that
I get out of it dimensionality reduction
is the idea of reducing the number of
random variables under consideration
very often you'll collect a data set
that has hundreds to thousands of
different features maybe some of these
features are not that important maybe
they're unchanging or even if they are
changing it's not by much and so maybe
you want to remove them from
consideration that's when you use a
technique like dimensionality reduction
and this is really really important when
you're doing feature selection and
feature extraction in your real datasets
and you might also use it for other
techniques such as compression or
visualization so if you want to show
things on Excel right showing a thousand
dimensional object may be difficult you
might try to
get down to the the two or three
dimensions that are easiest to visualize
and of course you can use neural
networks for unsupervised learning as
well surprise surprise so as much as a
lot of the press you've seen has been on
things like image classification using
nice label datasets there's a lot of
work where you can apply it in an
unsupervised case and these are largely
used to find better representations for
data such as clustering and
dimensionality reduction and they're
really powerful because of their
nonlinear capability so one example I
won't spend way too much time on this is
an autoencoder
and the basic idea behind an
auto-encoders you're trying to find some
sort of a compressed representation for
data and the way we do this is by
changing the metric that we use to say
that the system has done a good job and
the metric is basically if I have a set
of input features that I'm passing in I
would like to do the best job in
reconstructing that input at my output
and what I do is I squeeze it through a
smaller number of layers which forms
this compressed representation for my
data set and so the idea here is how can
I pass my inputs through this sort of
narrow waist to come up with a
reconstructed input that's very similar
to my original input and so my metric in
this particular case is essentially the
difference between the input the
reconstructed input or the output and
the and the input and the compressed
representation you can kind of think of
as the reduced dimensionality version of
my problem we've also done some work on
replicator networks which are also
really really cool happy to chat about
that as well and finally we have talked
very briefly on reinforcement learning
and the the basic you know again at a
very high level the the reason
reinforcement learning is sort of
fundamentally different than supervised
or unsupervised learning is that you're
not passing in sort of a label
associated with an input feature so
there is no supervisor right or a person
that can label it but just a reward
signal and the feedback is often delayed
and time is important so it kind of
steps through a process and the agents
actions often change the input data that
it receives so just to maybe in the
interest of time just to give you
examples of where reinforcement learning
could work and why you would use a
technique like reinforcement learning so
flying stunts maneuvers in a helicopter
so you if your helicopter is straight
you say keep doing more of whatever
you're doing to keep it there
if the helicopter tips over you say stop
doing whatever you just did to do that
could you create a supervised learning
algorithm for doing this sure right you
would basically look for all the
configurations of your entire system
every time the helicopter was upright
and you would look for all the examples
where your helicopter was tipping over
or falling and you would basically say
okay you know my engine speed was this
much my rotor speed was this much and
there are probably people here who fly
helicopters so pardon me if I am
completely you know oversimplifying this
problem here however you could certainly
label it that way and say all these all
these configurations of the helicopter
meant the helicopter was upright all
these configurations of the helicopter
meant the helicopter was not upright
would be a pretty expensive and
difficult data collect to do not sure
how many people want to volunteer for
let's let's do all the ones where it
falls and and lots of other applications
beyond that so these are really useful
especially in cases where they're the
what you're trying to model is just
extremely complex and the other really
powerful thing is this tends to mimic
sort of human behavior and so they're
they're very useful in in those type of
applications
so a reward would just be it would be
very similar to you get points so you
have your algorithm that's basically
trying to maximize the number of points
that it receives for example and as you
do more it's very similar to what you or
I would consider a reward playing a
video game right every time I get points
I do more of the activities that make me
get points and in it's essentially the
same same concept over here all right so
with that I will conclude only 20
minutes behind schedule so you know I
guess the the long story short is
there's lots of exciting research into
AI and machine learning techniques out
here we did a one-hour view of this
broad field that research has dedicated
about six to seven decades of work
towards so my apologies to anyone who's
watching this or in the room who's
worked I just like jumped over the key
ingredients however and I think this is
most important to to this group is you
know and I kind of look at what are the
problems where AI has done really well
these are some of the key ingredients
sort of data availability computing
infrastructure and the domain expertise
and algorithms and I think it's very
exciting to see this group over here
because we do have all of these pieces
sort of coming together so great things
are bound to happen there are you know I
think large challenges and data
availability and readiness for AI which
is what we're going to sort of scrape
the scrape the edge off during this
class and some of the computing
infrastructure is something that we'll
be talking to you about in a couple of
minutes and if you're interested in some
of the more detailed look at any of
these things a number of us actually
wrote you know maybe a biased I think
it's a great great great write-up but no
I think it's useful it has its place
there's obviously a lot of lot of
material in here but we try to do our
best job to at least cite some of this
really really interesting work that's
going on in the field so with that I'll
pause for any additional questions but
thank you very much for your attention
you
you